merci Monsieur président merci madame la
Présidente de nous avoir invité à cette
audition je pense qu'il est toujours
intéressant de pouvoir présenter en fait
dans le détail ce qui se passe et
peut-être en complément monsieur le
Président de ce que vous avez évoqué
bien rappeler et se rappeler
collectivement que nous sommes sur une
politique publique qui est en forte
progression vous avez donné certains
chiffres mais je veux rappeler la date
de mise en oeuvre de ma prime rénove
l'ouverture du service et l'ouverture de
cette aide c'est faite le 1er janvier
2020 donc c'est une c'est une politique
finalement assez récente et celle et
genre est-ce que je souhaite partager
avec vous tous c'est c'est que c'est
évidemment une politique qui s'améliore
en tout cas ce évolue quasiment chaque
année et donc monsieur le Président du
conseil d'administration de Lana vient
de d'évoquer effectivement les pistes
que nous recherchons encore d'évolution
sur les mois et années à venir puisque
le parc de logement vous l'avez évoqué
également concerné en matière de
rénovation énergétique et d'une manière
générale d'amélioration de l'habitat il
n'y a pas que la rénovation énergétique
l'amélioration de l'habitat au sens
large du parc privé concerne plus de 20
millions de logements dans notre pays et
donc c'est une politique publique au
long cours
sur les trois questions madame la
Présidente que vous avez évoquées donc
le pilotage de la rénovation énergétique
est évidemment un sujet porté par deux
ministères le ministère de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires et le ministère de la Ville
et du Logement donc les deux ministres
en charge de ces sujets
puisque cela concerne beaucoup de
beaucoup d'édifices en fait dans notre
pays et si on en reste aux politiques de
l'habitat évidemment il y a le logement
social sur le pour lequel Lana n'est pas
du tout légitime ni concernée et puis
évidemment ce parc privé que vous
souhaitez que nous évoquions ce matin
pour ce qui nous concerne nous avons
donc créé effectivement ma prime rénov
au 1er janvier 2020 et je pense qu'il
est important de partager avec vous que
ma prime rénov c'est une famille d'aide
président Repentin l'a évoqué on a ma
prime rénov aide nationale qui est basée
sur des forfaits des forfaits qui sont
particulièrement importants pour les
ménages les plus vulnérables et les plus
de notre pays et qui sont évidemment
moins intéressants ou moins important en
termes financiers que ceux qui sont
dédiés au ménage les plus aisés et puis
il y a ma prime rénove sérénité qui
permet de réaliser une rénovation
globale chez les ménages des 4 premiers
des cils de la population française et
ma prime rénov copropriété qui est une
aide destinée aux syndicat de
copropriétaires qui est une aide
collective et qui s'adresse à tous les
propriétaires occupants et tous les
propriétaires bailleurs dont de ces
ensembles immobiliers donc lorsque l'on
parle de ma prime rénov lorsque l'on
énonce un certain nombre de chiffres en
fait il faut bien avoir en tête que on
est face à une gamme d'aide différente
et que évidemment les sujets ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes selon le type
d'aide sollicité et ce qui est très
important aussi à partager avec vous
c'est que ma prime rénov c'est une
infinité et ma prime rénov copropriété
sont des aides à la pierre donc des
aides qui sont délégués dans les
territoires auprès je préfère et qui
sont contractualisés avec les
collectivités territoriales et donc des
aides qui sont décidés au niveau local
dans les politiques locales de l'habitat
et des aides qui sont donc abondées par
les collectivités territoriales ce qui
permet de réduire le reste à charge des
ménages qui sont concernés par ces aides
et bien sûr des aides qui pour y accéder
doivent
enfin oblige le ménage à être accompagné
j'y reviendrai donc on est déjà dans des
dispositifs d'accompagnement avec ce
tiers de confiance que qui évoquait le
président Repentin qui permette
effectivement à ces ménages d'être
sécurisés donc voilà ce que ce que je
voulais rappeler et peut-être pour
revenir sur un certain nombre de
chiffres depuis 2020 donc quasiment 1,5
millions de ménages ont pu être financés
ce qui est considérable vous évoquez
monsieur le Président que l'activité de
l'agence a été multipliée par 10 son
budget a été multiplié par 5 mais
l'activité de l'agence a été multipliée
par 10 en l'espace d'un quinquennat cela
généré 6,2 milliards de primes financés
et générer 18,8 milliards d'euros de
travaux dans les logements ce qui est
aussi extrêmement important et en termes
de rénovation globale c'est 163000
logements qui ont pu bénéficier d'une
rénovation globale et qui ont pu être
financés sur la même période donc depuis
2020 et qui ont généré 1,8 milliards
d'euros de primes financées donc les
chiffres je ne conteste pas en fait au
travers de ce propos les chiffres de la
Cour des comptes mais la Cour des
comptes en fait a examiné dans son
rapport ma prime rénov nationale au
forfait et à regarder des bonus mais n'a
pas regardé l'ensemble de la famille des
aides c'est à dire l'aide nationale et
les aides à la pierre qui sont donc
contractualisés avec les collectivités
et donc il était important aussi de
revenir sur
cette vision globale à la fois sur cette
aide nationale et sur les aides à la
pierre et de bien partager avec vous que
lorsque l'on remet ces chiffres en
perspective on est deux de toute façon
en deçà de ce qui peut être attendu en
matière de rénovation globale en matière
de confort thermique dans les logements
complets en matière de moindre émission
de gaz à effet de serre voire de zéro
émission de gaz à effet de serre mais
pour autant le pourcentage et le volume
sont plus importants que ce qui on ne
regarde qu'une portion donc des données
des données de l'activité de l'agence
donc voilà sur sur ces questions de
rénovation énergétique et bien sûr je
pourrais détailler à l'aune de vos
questions en ce qui concerne France
Renov France rénov est un service public
qui a été introduit par la loi climat
résilience et qui a été créé au 1er
janvier dernier donc il a il fait très
bientôt
[Musique]
mon avis des usagers qui souhaitent
pouvoir réaliser un diagnostic de leur
logement comprendre quels sont les mots
maux de ce logement les travaux qu'ils
doivent réaliser à l'intérieur de ce
logement et évidemment être conseillé le
mieux possible par rapport au parcours
de travaux qu'ils peuvent réaliser donc
ce réseau aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté il est piloté par la nappe
il est animé par Lana nous avons nous
l'avons réuni dans sa totalité
de lors de la première quinzaine de du
mois de septembre dernier à Angers nous
avions plus de plus de 1 milliers de
personnes en salle et plus de 500
personnes connectées donc qui était très
attentif pendant deux jours d'ailleurs
au divers débats à la fois de politique
publique et des débats très techniques
aussi que nous avons pu avoir en atelier
avec eux et ce qui est important d'avoir
en tête c'est que c'est un réseau qui
augmente chaque année c'est à dire que
on a chaque année un nombre d'opérations
programmées d'amélioration qui augmente
un nombre de programmes d'intérêts
généraux qui augmentaient qui augmentent
également et évidemment un nombre
d'espaces conseils France rénov qui
augmente sur le territoire on est
aujourd'hui à plus de 450 espaces
conseils France rénov et environ 2100
conseillers sur l'ensemble du territoire
national ce sont des derrière c'est
derrière ces chiffres ce sont des
individus ce sont des conseillers
essentiellement en amélioration de
l'habitat et en rénovation énergétique
qui sont plutôt des techniciens et qui
évidemment ont un objectif
quotidien c'est de d'orienter le ménage
dans le meilleur parcours de travaux
mais comme le disait le Président il y a
quelques minutes chaque ménage n'est pas
prêt à s'engager dans une rénovation
globale une rénovation globale enfin moi
je vais je vais vous le dire comme je le
dis systématiquement personne ni dans
cette salle ni ailleurs je crois mais
s'il y a s'il y a s'il y a une exception
à la règle
échangeant à ce sujet mais personne ne
se lève le matin en ayant envie de faire
des travaux chez soi faire des travaux
chez soi c'est intrusif ça ça provoque
toutes sortes de difficultés
on ne sait pas quand c'est fini
effectivement j'y reviendrai c'est la
question de l'émiments des filières et
des corps d'état est un sujet mais
personne n'a envie de faire des travaux
chez soi donc le tiers de confiance
je le tiers de confiance est
effectivement très important pour
sécuriser le ménage pour sécuriser le
ménage par rapport à l'offre de travaux
qui lui est fait par les entreprises
mais aussi pour s'assurer que les
travaux qu'il va réaliser sont sont de
seront de qualité et qu'il n'aura pas
forcément besoin d'y revenir mais il y a
des ménages qui de toute façon ne
s'engageront pas dans une démarche de
travaux global immédiatement et à qui il
faut pouvoir proposer un parcours de
travaux par étape et ceux qui ont se
sont engagés
ceux qui se sont engagés dans ce
parcours de travaux sont
des personnes vers lesquelles ces
conseillers France rénov que j'évoquais
doivent pouvoir revenir pour leur
permettre d'aller dans l'étape suivante
donc ce point est extrêmement important
mais en tout cas sur le pilotage du
réseau France rénov et sur l'animation
de ce réseau je vous confirme que Lana
est bien en charge de ce réseau et que
sur les modalités de financement ce
réseau reste Co c'est d'un côté par la
LinkedIn générique budgétaire de
l'agence c'est-à-dire les financements
des opas et des programmes d'intérêt
généraux et de l'autre côté par le
programme SAR porté par l'ADEME même si
nous assurons aujourd'hui le pilotage
global de cet ensemble ensuite sur
l'accélération de la rénovation globale
en fait j'ai déjà posé quelques quelques
éléments
il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs il y a
plusieurs ingrédients si vous permettez
de le formulaire ainsi il y a bien sûr
les aides publiques et le président l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure
le sujet de ma prime rénove est une aide
effectivement
différente suivant le type de ménage et
suivant évidemment la démarche de
travaux dans laquelle il a envie de
s'engager
cette aide nous espérons effectivement
au conseil d'administration pouvoir
prendre en compte pour l'année 2023 les
effets de l'inflation de façon à ce que
effectivement les les difficultés
rencontrées par les ménages et les
entreprises aussi sur sur les
territoires puissent être prendre en
compte prise en compte dans ce dans
cette dans cette
dans cette solvabilisation des ménages
le deuxième élément fondamental c'est la
politique locale c'est le portage
politique une politique d'amélioration
de l'habitat privé de rénovation
énergétique de l'habitat privé
nécessite
une proximité avec les usagers et un
portage politique très fort on voit bien
dans le distinguo des opérations
programmées d'amélioration de l'habitat
qu'il y en a qui sont extrêmement
productives avec des objectifs ambitieux
qui sont atteints au bout de la durée de
ces opérations et d'autres opérations
qui sont plus difficiles tout dépend
évidemment des moyens qui sont mis et du
portage qui est opéré la réussite dépend
aussi de la qualité des opérateurs les
opérateurs sont évidemment les
accompagnateurs mais on sait qu'on est
face à des publics très différents à des
structures très différentes
au plan juridique bien entendu mais
surtout des profils en fait de
professionnels différents on sait qu'on
a des territoires qui attirent plus ou
moins ces structures soient associatives
soit privée donc évidemment le sujet est
variable et puis enfin la question des
entreprises la question du Réseau des
entreprises évidemment de la densité
d'existence sur certains territoires ou
du manque parfois sur d'autres de leur
carnet de commandes qui sont très
complets du peut-être manque de main
d'oeuvre dans certains champs et puis
enfin de la question de l'émettement on
a aujourd'hui un réseau d'entreprises
général qui est très
performant très existants sur pour
réaliser des travaux de grande ampleur
notamment dans le champ du logement
social en revanche dans le champ du parc
privé face à des particuliers dans leur
appartement ou dans leur maison
individuelle ils sont face en fait à des
réseaux de corps d'état séparés qui ne
sont pas forcément organisés pour
pouvoir réaliser des travaux globaux et
donc une opération complète
d'amélioration du logement et notamment
de sa performance thermique et puis
enfin la question de l'innovation dans
l'industrie notamment en matière
d'isolation d'isolation par l'extérieur
d'isolation par l'intérieur pour des
travaux plus rapides moins invasif moins
complexe ça restera invasif je ne crois
pas à la baguette magique en matière de
travaux dans le logement en milieu
occupé mais pour autant on a su faire
d'énormes avancées sur certains champs
techniques en matière de bâtiment et
dans ce domaine-là beaucoup de choses
sont réfléchies et sont en cours de de
propositions mais pour autant il faut
des produits évidemment qui peuvent être
mis en oeuvre de façon la plus rapide
possible et qui sont efficaces et qui
bien sûr sont accessibles à tous
voilà ce que je pouvais partager avec
vous pardon d'avoir été peut-être un peu
longue mais le sujet vous l'avez vous
l'avez pointé et riche et complexe merci
madame la Présidente merci Monsieur le
Madame la Directrice Générale
pardonnez-moi je vous donne voilà des
merci monsieur le Président vous êtes
fort nombreux à avoir des questions donc
je vais d'abord donner la parole à
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne puis à Daniel
kremillat je vous le montrerai de
répondre et ensuite on prendra
l'ensemble des questions et je
demanderai à mes collègues évidemment
d'être précis et concis comme d'habitude
et non redondant voilà Dominique merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice générale
je voudrais bien sûr revenir sur
certains sujets que vous avez déjà
évoqué dans vos propos soit pour les
préciser et les compléter est-ce que la
NA va véritablement bouger les curseurs
pour mieux accompagner les ménages alors
vous l'avez dit tous les deux et on en
est tous conscients aujourd'hui une ré
globale elle n'est pas nécessairement
mieux aidé par ma prime rénove que des
gestes uniques est-ce que cela va
changer donc vous avez parlé d'une
révision de la de la hausse des plafonds
de travaux vous avez parlé aussi de
l'adaptation à l'inflation que connaît
notre notre pays est-ce que c'est
curseurs vont véritablement bouger et
surtout dans les copropriétés comment
allez-vous accélérer même si vous avez
donné des chiffres qui sont en
progression de ma prime rénov copro
depuis 2020 jusqu'à l'année 2022
allez-vous doubler les aides pour les
copropriétaires modestes comme c'est
envisagé et surtout comment comptez-vous
mieux mobiliser les syndics les syndics
qu'ils ont un rôle central à jouer
auprès des copropriétaires et on voit
encore que les syndics sont peu
impliqués sur la question de la
rénovation globale quand on interroge
des copropriétaires une grande partie
d'entre eux disent qu'ils ont été peu
sens réaliser par les syndics sur la
rénovation globale comment comptez-vous
les mobiliser est-ce que cela passe par
la formation des professionnels voilà
donc pour la première question ensuite
je crois que le président repentant a
parlé du DPE avant et après les travaux
mais est-ce que pour autant vous allez
le rendre obligatoire se DPE aujourd'hui
c'est assez rare et on a beaucoup de mal
à mesurer vous l'avez dit les gains qui
sont
engrangés en termes de gaz à effet de
serre et de sortie surtout de passoire
thermique ce qui provoque de nombreuses
critiques mais les diagnostiquers
sont-ils aujourd'hui à même de répondre
à la demande et Lana peut-elle le
financer enfin on dit souvent que le
guichet unique c'est en fait un guichet
de plus je voudrais que vous nous
expliquiez comment le nouveau numéro de
téléphone d'information ainsi que la
plateforme digitale France
avec les différents réseaux de services
d'information qui existaient avant
d'être rassemblés dans le réseau France
rénov enfin est-il prévu de modifier
l'organisation actuelle du réseau pour
assurer une couverture qui soit plus
homogène sur l'ensemble du territoire un
partenariat avec les maisons France
service est-il envisagé et dernière
question vous n'y avez pas fait
référence quid de ma prime adapte qui
est donc une aide à l'adaptation des
logements au vieillissement de la
population
tant sur l'éligibilité de cette prime a
primadapte que sur son financement merci
merci Dominique Daniel Gremillet
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président Madame la Directrice
Générale mes chers collègues dans le
cadre de mes travaux budgétaires sur les
crédits énergie du PLF pour 2023 je me
suis félicité de la massification de ma
prime rénove tout en relevant c'est
limite et j'en retiens deux et je
prolonge ce que vient de dire ma
collègue Dominique Estrosi ça sonne la
première limite concerne ces conditions
d'éligibilité il me semble que l'accès à
la prime des propriétaires bailleurs et
des syndicats de copropriété doit encore
progresser en 2021
3619 propriétaires bailleurs ont
persuades soit 0,95% du total des
versements et 162 copropriétaires l'ont
demandé soit 0-02% du total des demandes
de plus l'accès à la prime des ménages
intermédiaires et supérieurs et qu'il
s'achève cette fin d'année doit être
progée nous l'avons proposé dans le
cadre des lois de finances initiales et
rectificatives mais cela doit être
traduit réglementairement comment l'anal
compte-t-elle progresser dans le sens
d'une d'universalité dans la poussée de
la prime la seconde limite porte sur le
montant du reste à charge les
équipements éligibles et forfaits prévus
étant et limitées le montant moyen de
l'imprime et de 300023 euros en 2020
comment garantir dans ce contexte en
accompagnement suffisamment attractif
pour les ménages peut-on encore
améliorer l'articulation entre la prime
et les autres dispositifs de soutien
budgétaire ou extra budgétaire existants
je pense notamment au C2E dont les
montants sont élevés et le coût
budgétaire nul mais qui constitue un
vrai maquis pour les ménages ne
pourrait-on pas renforcer une
information délivrée par le réseau
France rénov à ce sujet merci
monsieur le Président ou Madame la
Directrice générale je fais qui de vous
de répondre
alors je vais prendre des questions dans
dans l'ordre peut-être en précisant
comme le disait le président tout à
l'heure que notre conseil
d'administration qui prendra un certain
nombre de décisions se tient la semaine
prochaine enfin celui sur les
délibérations techniques et sur le
budget initial 2023 donc il est
difficile ce matin de pouvoir vous
assurer de évidemment de du résultat de
de ce vote de ce de ces votes de la
semaine prochaine en revanche ce que
l'on peut partager avec vous c'est que
oui Lana travaille avec ses tutelles ces
tutelles techniques donc ministère du
Logement et évidemment ministère en
charge des questions d'énergie sur
l'évolution de ces aides c'était le sens
je pense de nos propos introductifs en
faveur bien entendu de la rénovation
globale et c'est donc et c'est un enfin
je vais vous le dire de cette manière là
le c'est un travail de longue haleine
c'est à dire que on a une première étape
2023 qui est une réponse aux questions
d'inflation et puis on travaille sur des
évolutions plus substantielles de
rééquilibrage de convergence comme
celles qu'on a déjà pu réaliser à la
première étape de convergence était bien
sûr de transformer un crédit d'impôt
en une aide directe avec une évidemment
une orientation sociale très importante
on a aussi fait converger déjà beaucoup
de critères mais on a encore des étapes
à franchir et c'est tous les travaux qui
bien sûr vont nous animer comme je vous
le disais avec nos tutelles à compter de
l'année prochaine et en fait qui nous
qui nous anime déjà pour améliorer la
rénovation globale en copropriété vous
avez si vous permettez à la fois poser
la question et présenter un élément de
réponse effectivement les syndics enfin
en fait on a un duo on a un duo syndic
maître d'oeuvre architectes qui est
fondamental il se trouve que que j'étais
avec le ministre de la Ville et du
logement dans le sud
dans le sud de la Seine-et-Marne la
semaine dernière nous avons visité une
copropriété qui a fait qui a fait une
rénovation globale
en 80 lots en trois édifices qui a fait
une rénovation globale sur les deux
années les échafaudages avaient été
retirés une semaine avant la visite et
une rénovation globale donc complète sur
trois trois ensembles immobiliers 80
logements la chose était claire les
aides ont été évidemment très enfin
apporté beaucoup de satisfaction
évidemment aux copropriétaires mais il y
avait quelque chose de très lisible dans
les échanges de cette matinée
premièrement un président de conseil
syndical extrêmement impliqué dans la
démarche un syndic extrêmement impliqué
également et un maître d'oeuvre un
architecte extrêmement impliqué aussi
ils ont ils ont constitué un trio qui a
permis pendant deux ans d'obtenir le
vote en assemblée générale de convaincre
et ensuite bien entendu de suivre les
travaux moi j'ai bien compris que la
première année de conviction avait été
finalement l'année presque la plus
complexe et la plus dense en énergie
développée par ces trois par ces trois
acteurs donc du coup effectivement la
formation l'implication des syndics est
extrêmement importante après ce que je
peux partager avec vous c'est que bien
sûr on a un axe de formation et
d'échange avec eux mais que j'étais hier
au congrès de la fnaïm et que pour la
première fois parce que bon j'y vais pas
j'y vais pas systématiquement mais en
tout cas pour la première fois depuis
maintenant un certain nombre d'années la
salle était comble sur les sujets
rénovation énergétiques et sur les
échanges qu'on a pu avoir à la fois avec
la présidence de la fenaïm mais aussi
avec la FFB qui était présente avec
Saint-Gobain qui était présent aussi et
aussi avec des représentants de de
structures qui accompagnent les ménages
et que les syndics posent de plus en
plus de questions sur ces sujets donc on
a un axe de formation très important et
puis bien sûr l'évolution des aides que
vous avez évoquées fait partie des
discussions de la semaine prochaine dont
nous espérons effectivement
effectivement en première étape je le
dis bien en première étape obtenir
effectivement des voies de favorables
sur le diagnostic de performance
énergétique en fait c'est la question de
l'évaluation avant travaux et après
travaux donc sur ma prime rénov
copropriété sur ma prime rénov sérénité
c'est déjà une obligation puisqu'on
mesure le gain énergétique c'est le
diagnostic enfin c'est un c'est ce qu'on
appelle un audit en fait et aujourd'hui
nous travaillons donc sur la convergence
évidemment de cette audit avec le
diagnostic de performance énergétique et
effectivement dans nos travaux à venir
l'implication ou plutôt l'implémentation
et l'obligation de ce diagnostic
préalable et de ce diagnostic final
effectivement fait partie des pistes de
réflexion c'est le moyen effectivement
de s'assurer qu'on a un gain énergétique
et un gain énergétique mesuré dans
chaque logement en sachant que les
chiffres que l'on a aujourd'hui sur ma
prime rénov nationale sont des chiffres
de mesure conventionnelles et donc il
faut qu'on puisse effectivement avoir
quelque chose de plus précis et de plus
et qui s'inscrit dans la réalité
pour autant je partage avec vous qu'à
partir du moment où évidemment on
inscrira ou s'inscrirait je préfère le
dire aux conditionnel c'est obligation
le parcours du ménage devient évidemment
plus complexe parce que il aura
évidemment des pièces supplémentaires et
un acte supplémentaire à réaliser mais
l'accompagnement devrait évidemment
l'aider dans ce parcours
sur France rénove comment se fait
l'articulation donc la plateforme France
rénov effectivement
s'appuient sa dose sur une plateforme
numérique qui a été créée au 1er janvier
dernier et à partir de cette plateforme
soit en prise de contact téléphonique
soit évidemment en
accès numérique sur cette plateforme on
est dirigé immédiatement vers les
structures locales immédiatement vers
les structures locales c'est-à-dire
qu'il suffit sur la plateforme de
rentrer son adresse pour être mis en
contact en fait avec enfin
on obtient l'adresse et le numéro de
téléphone du réseau le plus proche de
chez de chez soi et lorsqu'on téléphone
on est mis en contact directement avec
le réseau le réseau local et une
convention est en cours de préparation
avec l'Agence nationale de cohésion des
territoires pour effectivement faire le
lien avec les maisons France services
alors ça existe déjà en fait dans
certains territoires il y a déjà des
permanences rénove dans les maisons
France services mais par contre ce n'est
pas sur l'ensemble du territoire
national et l'objectif c'est évidemment
de généraliser mais on a des territoires
qui n'ont pas attendu une convention de
niveau national pour le faire et
l'objectif aussi c'est d'impliquer les
maisons françaises pour un certain
nombre d'usagers qui sont éloignés du
numérique et qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement pour pouvoir accéder à
ces plateformes et faire leur demande je
continue sur les questions de rénovation
énergétique sur les limites de ma prime
rénov notamment pour les propriétaires
bailleurs
un gros travail alors pour les
propriétaires bailleurs je vais je
voudrais revenir sur ce qui existe déjà
en fait il y a trois aides il y a deux
aides qui sont des aides aux travaux il
y a ma prime rénov propriétaire bailleur
et il y a habité mieux sérénité
propriétaire bailleur qui leur
permettent de réaliser des travaux
massifs dans leur logement et ce que
l'on constate au travers des
financements de la nasse et que les
propriétaires bailleurs qui s'engagent
dans ce type de dans ce type de démarche
réalisent des travaux d'ampleur c'est à
dire en moyenne le bouquet de travaux
est aux alentours de 50000 euros voire
il peut monter jusqu'à 60 000 euros de
montant de travaux ce qui s'oriente
plutôt vers ma prime rénov ma prime
rénove sont des propriétaires qui sont
plutôt propriétaires bailleurs qui font
un changement d'équipement à un moment
donné et uniquement un changement
d'équipement et là on est sur des
montants de travaux effectivement qui
sont plus qui sont plus modestes
ce que l'on constate et vous l'avez
effectivement pointé au travers des
chiffres c'est qu'on a peu de
propriétaires bailleurs qui s'orientent
quand même vers ces demandes de travaux
enfin ces demandes d'aide pour pouvoir
réaliser des travaux et la question
reste pleine et entière notamment
contenu des des contraintes qui
s'imposent aux propriétaires ailleurs au
travers de la loi climat résilience et
donc on va travailler dans les dans les
prochains mois à une convergence
c'est-à-dire faire en sorte que
finalement il n'y ait qu'un seul
peut-être dispositif pour leur permettre
de pour leur permettre finalement de
d'avoir une aide la plus simple possible
pour pouvoir réaliser ses travaux et
puis ensuite on a eu l'aide une aide
fiscale qui est locavage qui
l'a continue enfin en tout cas les
chiffres qu'on sortira début 2022
montreront que on est toujours sur une
tendance plutôt haussière mais
modestement c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
une envolée de sollicitations de sa tête
fiscale mais pour autant on n'est pas
non plus on n'est pas dans la continuité
on voit que de plus en plus de
propriétaires bailleurs la sollicitent
mais pas de façon massive et en tout cas
pas de façon suffisante pour pouvoir
réellement traiter l'ensemble du parc et
sur la question du reste à charge
effectivement le montant moyen de l'aide
ma prime rénov est aux alentours de 3000
euros sur ma prime rénov nationale parce
qu'on est sur un changement d'équipement
et qu'on moyenne évidemment les aides
aux propriétaires les plus les plus
les plus
aisés voilà et ceux qui évidemment sont
les plus vulnérables ce que l'on
constate c'est que quand même les les
forfaits qui sont sollicités concernent
des équipements des carbonés donc pompe
à chaleur chaudière à granulés poêle à
granulés donc de plus en plus alors que
au moment où ma prime rénov a été créée
on avait beaucoup de demandes en
chaudière gaz même THPE mais aujourd'hui
vraiment il y a voilà il y a vraiment
mais mais l'inflexion s'est fait dès
2021 donc voilà 2020 on était encore
beaucoup dans cette tendance chaudière
gaz et HPE et puis à partir de l'année
2021 le forfaits les forfaits des cartes
d'équipements des carbonées ont été très
sollicités et sur les C2E
c'est ce que le président évoquait tout
à l'heure ils ont enfin les ménages
d'une manière générale sollicitent les
c2eux quand il sollicite ma prime rénov
quasiment systématiquement mais au
travers des entreprises au travers des
entreprises en tout cas dans les
déclarations qu'il nous faut sur la
plateforme on voit bien que c'est ces
deux œufs sont sollicités simplement les
critères enfin le principe de
convergence des critères et de
sollicitations de ces C2E doit être
améliorée mais laisser deux oeufs comme
vous l'avez dit c'est c'est une aide en
fait au fond entre guillemets privés et
pas une aide publique et c'est toute la
complexité des travaux qui sont devant
nous
et ma primadap alors ma fille m'adapte
pardon je suis longue mais les questions
sont très riches ma Primada donc
effectivement le gouvernement a annoncé
cette nouvelle aide pour normalement
début d'année 2024 donc nous y
travaillons nous y travaillons dans un
registre évidemment de création d'une
nouvelle aide je le rappelle l'objectif
c'est de fusionner l'aide qui existe
déjà côté Anna qui s'appelle habiter
facile le crédit d'impôt et les aides de
la CNAV donc et d'avoir grâce à ce à
cette se rapprochement et cette fusion
de trois aides d'avoir une seule aide
existante donc plus simple plus simple à
capter et par ailleurs évidemment avec
une augmentation du plafond de travaux
et une augmentation de l'aide par
ailleurs en terme de périmètre c'est une
aide qui sera des qui sera
destiné pardon au ménage les plus
modestes donc les quatre premiers des
cils de la population française ménage
en situation de perte d'autonomie soit
en raison de de leur âge soit en raison
d'un handicap et la l'objectif je crois
que le ministre l'a dit au moment d'un
colloque au mois d'octobre et que ma
Primada soit une aide à la pierre
rapidement revenir sur deux points sur
la question des syndics qui est une
question très importante dans l'acte de
décision
la réussite d'une politique publique
c'est les moyens qui sont mis par la
nation les collectivités territoriales
mais sur ce sujet là on est sur des
décisions vous l'avez bien compris
d'individus seul dans leur maison ou
d'individus agrégés dans une copropriété
je j'ai assisté comme Elie locale il se
présente chargé de l'habitation mon
territoire à plusieurs assemblées
générales de copropriété au cours des
derniers mois pour des actes de décision
de s'engager ou non très franchement
j'ai trouvé que l'ambiance est bien plus
difficile que qu'une campagne électorale
si je peux faire
une comparaison c'est d'une très grande
violence
ressortent dans ces discussions les
problèmes de voisinage
des stratégies qui sont assez
différentes au sein d'une copropriété
entre un propriétaire occupant un
propriétaire bailleur propriétaire
multibailleur qui a une stratégie
patrimoniale dans beaucoup de
immeuble de votre de votre ville et je
ne sais pas si certaines ou certains ont
eu la chance de voir un film qui est
sorti il y a quelques mois sur les
grands écrans que s'appelait les
promesses
de l'histoire d'une mère d'une ville de
banlieue jouée par Madame Isabelle
Huppert qui est confronté à un problème
d'une copropriété ce film est admirable
pour voir quels sont les stratégies au
sein d'une copropriété et comment la
puissance publique se heurte à une non
décision et Madame stratégie stason
c'est vous qui avez posé la question
c'est vrai que
c'est la différence entre le logement
public et le logement privé car au
moment où la loi climat est résilience a
été adoptée le parc public consomme 30%
d'énergie de moins que le parc privé 50%
d'eau de moins que le parc privé parce
que vous avez des stratégies d'entretien
du patrimoine et à s'indique qui en
l'occurrence le directeur de l'organisme
HLM avec des représentants de locataires
qui ont un rôle de sensibilisation
parfois des collectivités territoriales
derrière c'est pour cela que la question
des syndics est très importante et que
on voit sur le territoire des réunions
aussi qui sont organisées par les EPCI à
destination des syndics pour les former
à cette question de la sensibilisation
sur la donnée environnementale voilà
donc c'est un vrai vrai travail le
représentant des syndics qui siègent au
conseil d'administration de Lana nous
dit que la durée moyenne entre
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour du
dossier de rénovation et la réalisation
c'est 6 ans et demi
dans une copropriété privée voilà c'est
un vrai sujet qui peut aussi expliquer
pourquoi dans une politique même s'il y
a des moyens il peut y avoir une prise
de décision bien plus difficile qu'on ne
l'imaginent alors des textes sur
l'obligation de faire des travaux sinon
vous pouvez pas louer augmenter les
loyers etc avant sans doute aider à la
prise de décision mais et c'est pour ça
qu'il y aura on a l'espoir de voir une
croissance assez forte dans les années
qui viennent parce que il y a ces
obligations réglementaires et que
certains propriétaires bailleurs vont
aussi se dire mince je peux plus louer
je peux plus changer le loyer ça va sans
doute nous aider mais les assemblées
générales sont vraiment très très
difficiles la dernière chose c'est un
complément sur
France rénov le tiers de confiance c'est
vraiment très important
il y a des gens qui viennent qui
poussent la porte ils savent pas ce
qu'il faut faire et donc ils vont avoir
en phase 2 quelqu'un qui vont leur dire
bah écoutez nous on a besoin de quoi
faut que vous nous ameniez si possible
si vous les avez les plantes
construction de votre habitation quel
est l'orientation de votre habitation en
quelle année elle a été faite puisque
les normes thermiques de la décennie 70
n'est pas le même que les années 80
qu'avez-vous fait vous-même quel est le
vitrage de ce que c'est du simple
vitrage double vitrage et des gens
viennent sans aucune idée préconçue sauf
qu'ils savent que ils vont s'engager de
sur les travaux qui peuvent être
effectivement très perturbants pour leur
vie quotidienne et puis vous avez une
partie qui ont travaillé et qui se
disent voilà nous on va faire ça faut
savoir que les ménages qui viennent avec
un projet tout fait la moitié change le
projet la moitié change le projet
lorsqu'ils ont vu le conseiller France
Renov
parce que ils ont eu un conseil ou des
idées préconçues
ont été remises en cause la priorité
c'est le changement du vitrage bah non
c'est plutôt l'isolation du toit des
murs et ensuite voilà donc c'est très
important qu'il puisse venir en se
disant je vais avoir un conseil sans que
derrière il y a un intérêt de celui qui
me qui me conseille faites l'expérience
si vous pouvez vous-même alors c'est
quand on essaierateur c'est difficile
parce qu'on est clairement identifié moi
je l'ai fait à titre personnel voilà en
allant poser un projet et vous revenez
effectivement
avec une réflexion qui est pas la même
c'est important qu'on puisse nous
assurer quand on pousse la porte de
France rénov on est ce conseil qui
puisse éclairer utilement chaque dossier
est un cas particulier je vous assure
chaque dossier voilà donc c'est
important je voulais simplement vous
leur dire c'est que c'est aussi notre
demande d'explication la plus pertinente
pour celles et ceux qui viennent nous
voir merci monsieur le Président alors
j'ai demandé à mes collègues d'être
concis dans leur question puisque vous
êtes encore 17 à devoir poser des
questions Olivier Ritman ensuite Laurent
saumon oui merci madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président et Madame
l'annéehatrie générale je vais vous
parler d'un sujet qui remonte
régulièrement au niveau de la présidente
et je remercie vraiment madame la
Présidente d'avoir organisé cette
audition parce qu'on est un certain
nombre et je trouve que vous avez parlé
du sujet mais de manière plutôt
superficielle alors que c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui qui pourrit la vie de
certains de nos concitoyens qui ont
monté des dossiers m'imprime rénov et
qui aujourd'hui n'y voit pas d'issue au
bout de six mois au bout d'un an au bout
d'un an et demi alors que des dépenses
ont été engagés il y a la même qui se
retrouvent dans des situations hors de
réaliser des prêts bancaires pour payer
des travaux et quelquefois uniquement
par un manque de communication vous
l'avez dit Madame la Directrice
aujourd'hui on met en place et on fait
en sorte que sur les territoires y ait
des interlocuteurs notamment ma prime
rénove territorialisée et on se rend
compte d'une chose c'est qu'à la fois on
a une plateforme nationale qui traite
les dossiers à la fois on a des
interlocuteurs territoriaux mais il y a
pas de communication dans les deux sens
entre les deux et du rapport même de la
veuve même du directeur de la DDT de la
Haute-Saône cette semaine il me dit nous
on peut faire remonter les choses mais
on n'a aucune vision sur les dossiers
leur instruction où ça en est et on n'a
pas de descente et la même chose pour
les les conseillers France rénov
territoriaux et on a moi j'ai sous les
yeux des dossiers qui datent depuis un
an sur des petits détails et on se rend
compte que ma prime rénove c'est vrai
c'est quelque chose de très important
qui nous permettra d'arriver à des
objectifs écologiques environnementaux
dans les 20 ans qui viennent mais qui
suffit d'un petit grain de sable pour
que la vie de nos concitoyens soit
complètement pourri alors j'aimerais
qu'on ait des interlocuteurs d'ailleurs
ce ce sujet a été montré du doigt par la
Défenseur des droits dans un communiqué
de presse qui date de fin octobre et qui
parle d'hyper des matérialisation et
d'hypersentralisation où on en est dans
la volonté de régler ses problèmes et
nous en tant que sénateur on est
régulièrement sollicité par nos
concitoyens vers qui devons-nous nous
adresser pour avoir enfin des réponses
et déverrouiller ces dossiers sur
lesquels on ne voit pas d'issue merci
beaucoup Olivier Laurent saumon ensuite
Viviane Martigues
monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice Générale effectivement ça va
revenir un petit peu sur ce qui vient
d'être dit mais à propos en particulier
du du logement insalubre
parce que vous avez parlé effectivement
que l'intérêt de cette politique c'était
la massification et vous avez également
dit effectivement que c'était il y avait
des spécificités individuels et qu'il
fallait accompagner chaque Français et
c'est véritablement le cas que vient
d'évoquer Olivia Ritman et que je veux
aussi vous poser parce que de la
nécessité au projet et du projet au
concret et bien c'est un parcours du
combattant les délais de difficultés
vous avez dit
[Musique]
la maîtrise d'oeuvre d'une part et de la
sollicitation et de la mobilisation des
entreprises sans qu'elles soient des
comment dire des marchands de sommeil et
qu'il faut donc bien les labelliser
est-ce qu'il y a une proposition qui est
faite en ce sens sur la labilisation des
entreprises sur la possibilité d'avoir
comme le propose par exemple lors des
architectes donc une maîtrise d'ouvrage
qui soit proposée aux EPCI pour pouvoir
les accompagner et puis un point qui a
été oublié quand même important et dont
Olivier Rickman vient de pointer c'est
les avances les régies d'avance il y a
bien sûr des collectivités des EPCI qui
s'y sont engagés personnellement voici
engager au niveau du conseil
départemental de mon département mais on
voit bien qu'il y a une difficulté pour
engager les financements et donc ça
montre bien que ce parcours est
extrêmement compliqué quoi qu'en dit je
dirais les propos très enthousiasmants
vous avez pu nous tenir
de vous donner un exemple qui dure
depuis deux ans et demi qui est
absolument innommable
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président vous avez dit dans les
derniers de Lana que les 80 % des
logements de 2005 ans existe déjà
effectivement j'en vois bien que c'est
pour
montrer l'importance de la rénovation
simplement bon on est on se dit aussi
que c'est peut-être aussi pour justifier
la panne dans la construction de
logements que nous avons actuellement
est-ce que vous pensez réellement que le
rythme de construction actuel
suffira pour répondre aux besoins de
logement abordable et des 2,2 millions
de personnes qui attendent un logement
social et qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
du dispositif second de vie de faire du
neuf dans dans l'ancien qui pourrait
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on pense sur la
question de la rénovation
on voit bien que les financements sont
là et vous l'avez bien montré que la
difficulté plutôt plus de vers la caisse
l'accompagnement et vers la filière
aussi qui est très atomisée sur la
question de l'accompagnement est-ce que
vous pensez parce que cet accompagnement
il est particulièrement difficile sur la
rénovation qui est très importante en
milieu rural dans les logements
améliorural est-ce que vous savez les
dispositifs dans vos structures locales
pour aller vers les habitants et
dernière chose sur la question de de ça
a été évoqué de ce qui pourrait exister
par rapport à la filière l'organisation
de la filière est-ce que il faudrait pas
mettre un autre ministère dans le Lot
celui de l'économie avec l'artisanat et
l'industrie
merci Viviane Amel gacquet ensuite
Jean-Claude Tissot madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice vous l'avez dit vous devrez
aujourd'hui dans un contexte qui vous
confère un rôle essentiel explosion des
coûts de l'énergie baisse du pouvoir
d'achat dérèglement climatiques et vous
êtes identifié aujourd'hui comme un
acteur majeur en matière de rénovation
l'augmentation des demandes notamment
une multiplication par 1050 on a testé
c'est dans ce cadre que je vous
interpelle il a été évoqué des
dysfonctionnements dans la gestion des
dossiers de ma prime rénov mais je
souhaite évoquer la situation de nos
concitoyens qui ne peuvent pas déposer
de dossiers qui ne poussent pas
forcément la porte des guichets
d'informations en effet la
dématérialisation complète de la
procédure nécessite une connexion
Internet nous savons que près de 13
millions des Français souffrent
d'électronisme ces Français sont aussi
souvent les plus modestes et les plus à
même de vous solliciter vous avez évoqué
Madame la Directrice brièvement
brièvement le sujet et compte tenu de
l'enjeu j'aimerais creuser en fait ce
sujet comment comptez-vous aujourd'hui
pallier à ce dysfonctionnement vous
adressez à ce public démuni face à
l'usage d'Internet est-ce qu'une action
particulière et prévue je vous remercie
merci
so ensuite Rémy Cardo merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice générale pour ma part je
souhaiterais revenir sur la question
spécifique de la rénovation thermique de
logements situés en zone rurale avec
près de 936 000 habitations concernées
soit un taux de 22% de ces territoires
pour ces territoires ruraux contre une
moyenne nationale fixée à 19,6%. à
l'exception de l'agglomération
parisienne ou taux est le plus élevé les
espaces ruraux sont donc légèrement
moins bien nautiques les logements dans
les plus grandes agglos l'explication
apportée est souvent l'ancienneté
attribuée aux constructions dans les
honorales ce qui n'est pas ce qui n'est
pourtant pas forcément le cas si on
établit une comparaison avec les
bâtiments urbains ainsi je souhaitais
connaître votre analyse sur les
difficultés rencontrées même si vous
avez abordé sujet là tout à l'heure par
la rénovation thermique dans ces
territoires le dispositif ma prime rénov
souvent mise en avant comme une grande
réussite par le gouvernement connaît de
pourtant de nombreuses problématiques
plusieurs collègues les ondes soulignés
et ne semble pas répondre à tous les
enjeux et ce que vient de souligner ma
collègue jaker est très en termes de
connexion et de capacité à utiliser le
les le numérique
pensez-vous qu'une adaptation ce
dispositif pour les territoires ruraux
pourrait être pertinents ou considérer
vous que d'autres politiques publiques
pourraient être plus efficaces merci
Claude
merci madame la Présidente ma question
effectivement
revenir tout simplement sur le rapport
du CESU qui dit en 2021 la rénovation
globale concernait moins de 1000
dossiers soit
0,2% des demandes financier en 2021 avec
un montant moyen de 3000 euros ça a été
dit tout à l'heure par mes collègues
mais vous dire aussi que en parallèle
fixement ça 14 % des ménages français
sont en situation de précarité
énergétique et c'est la raison pour
laquelle quand je vous entends dire
personne n'a envie de faire des travaux
chez soi vu l'augmentation des prix et
de l'électricité du gaz et vu le reste à
charge aussi qui est près de 40% pour
les plus modestes et ça c'est plusieurs
rapports qui le stipulent effectivement
il va falloir aussi mettre la main à la
pâte et accélérer et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vais vous poser
plusieurs questions
pensez-vous qu'il faille opérer une
simplification des dispositifs d'aide à
la rénovation thermique en essayant de
ménager les conditions d'accès
pensez-vous qu'un reste à charge
zéro à destination des propriétaires
modestes seraient une solution pour
accélérer la rénovation thermique des
logements et tout simplement aussi faire
un focus
pour justement stopper je dirais les
l'effet des rénovations monogestes
est-ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à soit
absorber ou supprimer ma prime rénov au
profit de ma prime
rénove sérénité je comprends que c'est
une porte d'entrée pour certains pour en
tout cas certains ménages mais dans ce
cas là faut-il clairement l'assumer que
c'est une porte d'entrée pour les
embarquer sur une une rénovation globale
et donc mettre des dispositions
incitatives pour les faire basculer sur
ma prime rénov sérénité alors est-ce que
c'est dans la en tout cas dans votre
feuille de route et puis j'ajouterai
aussi une remarque sur la situation de
ce qu'on entend sur le terrain notamment
sur les obligations les interdictions
qui pèsent sur les propriétaires dans
les dans les faits mais bien évidemment
ça ne s'applique
à de nombreuses personnes parce que par
exemple l'interdiction d'augmentation de
loyer ne s'applique pas un bail signé
avant le 24 août 2022 de même
l'interdiction de location ne
s'appliquera pas pour les logements les
plus consommateurs au 1er janvier si le
bail a été signé avant le 24 août donc
ce qui est gênant là-dedans c'est que
comment un locataire
dans le rapport de force entre le
propriétaire et le locataire comment un
locataire peut inciter son propriétaire
à à ne pas réviser le loyer parce qu'il
y ait des augmentations de loyer et
pourtant il est déclaré pas de sport
thermique depuis bien longtemps mais
sauf que son bail a été signé aussi
depuis bien longtemps donc là dessus je
trouve qu'il y a un rapport de force qui
est pas sain faut-il aller jusqu'à une
révision de loyer autorisée si et
seulement si le une mise à jour du DPE
enfin voilà je c'est un peu complexe
mais je je vous invite à y regarder
quand même
très bien merci Rémi Françoise Ferrat
ensuite Marie-Christine Chauvin oui
merci madame le Président de moi je
serai très rapide puisque ma question
rejoint celle de notre collègue
Dominique Estrosi Sassone et concernait
les divers plafonds et ça me semble
monsieur le Président un point
fondamental mais je voudrais profiter
d'avoir la parole pour vous apporter un
témoignage si on était besoin elle
permet dans mon département pour le pH
rénovation
urbaine cœur de ville 2000 logements et
4500 habitants sont concernés seuls
trois logements ont pu être traités en
deux ans sur les 2000 possibles
le niveau de ressources ne convient pas
pour les uns et les plafonds pour les
autres vous avouerez que c'est quand
même moins que peu
merci la rapidité l'intervention
Marie-Christine Chauvin oui à Noël merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la directrice Madame la
Directrice vous avez parlé de la
facilité pour accéder au Parcours du
système et je dois et là vous dire qu'il
y a de nombreux dysfonctionnements et là
je vais vous parler pas d'un petit grain
de sable mais d'un énorme grain de sable
qui met un couple en grande difficulté
dont le monsieur est à mobilité réduite
et il est accompagnant de sa femme qui
est également en situation de handicap
ce dossier dure depuis juin 2021 où il a
il a alerté son compte son compte ma
prime rénove a semble-t-il été piraté le
compte a été bloqué et depuis cette date
il demande quand lui supprime ce compte
pour qu'il puisse en créer un autre et à
ce jour et bien la situation n'est
toujours pas résolue il a sollicité une
dérogation pour pouvoir faire ses
travaux c'est pour une installation à
chaudière granulés bois il a passé
l'hiver
2021-2022 sans chauffage et la l'hiver
est là et son chauffage n'est toujours
pas installé donc il me semble que la
situation est vraiment dramatique et
dans cette fois il menace d'alerter les
médias parce que il n'a pas de réponse
moi j'ai également signalé le problème
on m'a dit qu'on allait contacter le
monsieur pour l'aider mais il n'y a
toujours pas d'avancer donc comment
comment aider ce monsieur pour la
dérogation on lui dit de joindre les
documents par le par votre site
évidemment il est bloqué il ne peut pas
joindre par le site il a tout envoyé par
mail il y a 15 jours et à ce jour il
attend toujours la réponse donc vraiment
je pense que si la situation est
urgente à résoudre merci Marie-Christine
Sylviane Noël ensuite Henri Cabanel
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice j'aurais
souhaité avoir plus d'informations sur
les missions de mon accompagnateur Renov
escau de là des conseils donnés aux
particuliers pour les diriger vers les
travaux d'économie d'énergie les plus
appropriées est-ce que se tir de
confiance aura également pour rôle de
les accompagner dans leur démarche
administratives car pour l'avoir vécu
personnellement et pour être plutôt
aguerri aux lourdeur administratives et
à l'outil informatique je peux
personnellement témoigner que c'est un
vrai parcours du combattant je rejoins
les nombreux témoignages qui m'ont
précédé et que la moindre erreur peut
amener et bien tout simplement à se voir
privé de ces aides c'est ma première
question est-ce qu'il y aurait pas quand
même nécessité de mettre en oeuvre un
principe de droit à l'erreur comme on le
connaît aujourd'hui endroit
administratif pour ne pas priver des
particuliers de bonne foi qui auront pas
cocher la bonne case au bon moment au
bon endroit de pouvoir malgré tout
percevoir leurs par ailleurs il faut en
moyenne 4 mois pour entre la fin des
travaux et le déblocage des aides que ce
soit des aides de Lana ou des
certificats d'économie d'énergie ce qui
est quand même considérable quand on
connaît le montant des travaux engagés
et puis enfin est-ce qu'il existe au
niveau de Lana un médiateur pour faire
face aux litiges que peuvent connaître
les usagers je pense notamment un couple
de retraités qui a fait changer sa
chaudière l'entreprise était censée
réaliser toutes les démarches chose
qu'elle n'a pas fait ou mal fait et
lorsque les travaux étaient terminés
l'entreprise a bien été payée par par
les clients en revanche eux n'ont pas
reçu l'aide promise par Lana de 5000
euros et donc sans recours possible au
bout du compte merci merci avec beaucoup
de respect je peut-être que si on peut
éviter toutes les petites histoires dans
tous les voilà on gagnera un tout petit
peu de temps je crois qu'on a
[Rires]
oui oui c'est bien sûr c'est bien sûr
c'est bien sûr révélateur vous êtes
libre de poser les questions que vous
voulez je suggère juste voilà Henri
cabane pardon oui Henri Cabanel et
ensuite Laurent Duplo merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice je vais revenir
essentiellement donc sur les demandeurs
qui ont été victimes de d'entreprises
donc peu scrupuleuses et qui se trouve
aujourd'hui dans des situations donc
assez difficile est-ce qu'on ne pourrait
pas imaginer par rapport donc au
conseiller que vous êtes vous avez mis
en place le fait de pouvoir compter sur
ses conseillers justement en cas de
problème pour les épauler face donc à
ces entreprises peu scrupuleuses et
justement pour éviter
un nombre quand même assez important
enfin moi je vois sur mon territoire il
y a quand même quelques entreprises
prescrupuleuses causer beaucoup de
dégâts par rapport à des demandeurs voir
pouvoir s'il n'était pas opportun de
mettre davantage de critères pour la
labellisation RGE des entreprises
merci beaucoup Henri Laurent Duplo
ensuite Serge mériou merci madame la
Présidente moi je voudrais poser une
question simple
une personne qui bénéficie des aides de
Lana
qui était éligible à ces aides
les travaux sont faits sur son domicile
ou sa maison
par contre cette personne
est propriétaire d'un certain patrimoine
ce patrimoine par la suite est vendue
pour plusieurs dizaines de milliers
voire centaines de milliers d'euros
est-ce que une fois que vous constatez
ces ventes Lana récupère les sommes qui
ont été versées au départ pour la
réhabilitation du logement
merci Laurent Serge mériou ensuite
Evelyne Renaud garabédian
tu n'avais pas demandé la parole alors
merci de la brièveté de tes propos
Evelyne vas-y
[Rires]
est-ce que conformément recommandations
de la Cour des comptes une évaluation
des bénéfices environnementaux et
sociaux du programme était le prévu et
la deuxième question est-ce qu'en fin
selon vous vous allez encourager la
rénovation avec un gain énergétique qui
soit supérieur à 50%
donc merci Madame président de Madame
directrice générale mes collègues en ont
parlé la procédure d'accès au dispositif
ma prime rénove rencontre des
difficultés comme l'indique d'ailleurs
le Défenseur des droits dans une
décision du mois d'octobre dernier face
au dysfonctionnements techniques qui
sont rencontrés sur la plateforme au
délai de traitement des dossiers à
l'absence de prise en compte des des
avis de dégrèvement certains demandeurs
n'ont pas pu accéder à cette aide si
Lana entend l'avenir résoudre les
problèmes comme vous l'avez indiqué des
dysfonctionnements pour permettre aux
futurs demandeurs d'accéder facilement à
cette aide qu'en sera-t-il de l'ensemble
des demandes qui ont précédemment été
faites et qui n'ont pas pu être réalisés
en raison des difficultés qui étaient
imputables à la mise en oeuvre du
dispositif merci de votre réponse merci
Evelyne Daniel salmon ensuite
Anne-Catherine Loisier
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice générale
je ne reviendrai pas sur le maquis
beaucoup beaucoup de choses ont été
dites effectivement la recherche de
lisibilité est toujours là votre exposé
était très touffue mais on voit bien que
c'est très complexe je reviendrai je
voudrais juste une question vous avez
parlé des rénovations par geste qui ne
doivent pas être qui doivent être prises
en compte pourtant toutes les études
montrent qu'il faut aller vers des
rénovations globales et que c'est
vraiment le maître mot pour avoir une
efficience doit-on continuer à
rembourser à aider les rénovations pour
un geste ou deux geste voilà moi c'est
c'est ma question et la citation
l'incitation montre aussi ses limites
l'obligation est-ce que pensez-vous de
l'obligation par exemple sur les
multipropriétaires bailleurs parce qu'on
sait on parle souvent du petit
propriétaire bailleur mais il y a
souvent des multiples propriétaires
merci
parce qu'il y a encore un côté gauche un
côté droit dans cette salle c'est
parfait
Anne Catherine Loisier madame Martine
Berthet monsieur le Président Madame
merci beaucoup pour toutes ces infos moi
j'aurais juste de petites questions
complémentaires pour mesurer
l'efficacité du dispositif à ce stade
vous avez parlé de 163000 madame
logement rénové je voudrais savoir
l'évolution en terme de classement de
ces logements et
et en matière de zonage est-ce que vous
avez un classement zonage urbain ou
ruraux merci
merci beaucoup Anne Catherine Martine
Berthet ensuite Micheline Jack oui merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice moi
j'aimerais vous parler des propriétaires
bailleurs dans l'immobilier touristique
de montagne la loi climat est résiliente
2021 faisait une exception jusque-là
mais des démarches sont-elles tout de
même engagées par des propriétaires ou
déco propriétaire Emmanuel wargon
parlait de la mise en oeuvre possible
une foncière immobilière par la Caisse
des Dépôts
lors d'une réponse à une question orale
est-ce qu'il a une future obligation je
pense aux annonces du ministre Olivier
Klein fin octobre sur une chaîne TV
merci
merci beaucoup Martine Micheline Jacques
nous emmène au micromètre
Monsieur le Directeur Madame la
Directrice générale
pendant le monsieur le Président
excusez-moi à la faveur du audition
réalisée en 2021 dans le cadre d'un
rapport sur le logement d'outre-mer à
l'initiative de la délégation
cinématoriale aux outre-mer vous nous
avez indiqué Madame la Directrice que
l'action de Lana se limitait au
dispositif ma prive rénov seul 700
dossiers avait été engagés en 2020 dans
les quatre cinquièmes concernés la
Réunion alors qu'il n'y en avait aucun
en Guyane et à Mayotte pour vais vous
indiquer si ce chiffre s'est amélioré si
la disparité entre les territoires
est-elle toujours aussi prononcée par
ailleurs des adaptations pour une
meilleure articulation entre les
financements via la LBU et les aides de
Lana étaient en cours de réflexion qu'en
est-il
merci Micheline Patrick Chauvet ensuite
Patricia Schlinger merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice au regard des échanges que
nous avons et pour à l'avoir vécu j'ai
une question très courte et très simple
vous avez prochainement un conseil
administration allez-vous envisager ou
proposer l'hypothèse de la
simplification merci à vous
merci Patrick et Patricia silinger oui
dernièrement il y a eu un reportage
l'interrogation
d'isolation de de camping de de
maison qui sont en location sur
temporairement ou saisonnier et il y a
des parfois des choses assez artistiques
donc en location et demander s'il
faisait partie aussi des aides
financières
merci beaucoup
au menu un grand nombre de questions
mais quelques thèmes récurrents je pense
alors je vais commencer sur les dossiers
en difficulté puisque
vous nous avez fait partager un certain
nombre de difficultés
la première chose je reviens sur les
chiffres qui vous ont été présentés par
le président
en début de en début d'audition Lana
prend 25 000 décisions par semaine donc
il y a 25000 mais non mais il y a 25000
ménages qui chaque semaine bénéficie de
ma prime rénov soit en engagement soit
en paiement la défenseur des doigts a
remonté
500 dossiers
50% de ces dossiers étaient traités au
moment de cette décision des dossiers en
difficulté existent existent vous me les
envoyez vous me les transmettez on va
les traiter ça c'est le premier point
c'est voilà c'est la proposition c'est
la proposition la proposition
vous me les envoyer non mais
vous me les envoyez
et on reçoit on reçoit régulièrement on
reçoit régulièrement des sollicitations
de parlementaires avec des dossiers qui
sont réglés effectivement il y en a il y
en aura toujours je souhaite vous le
dire il n'existe pas de système parfait
et derrière ces dossiers en difficulté
il y a eu des dysfonctionnements de la
plateforme en 2020 mais il y a aussi
effectivement des ménages qui n'arrivent
pas ou des entreprises qui n'arrivent
pas à nous déposer des dossiers complets
qui n'arrivent pas à déposer des
dossiers complets des factures
non-acquittées des factures qui ne
correspondent pas aux travaux réalisés
des contrôles sur place des contrôles
des contrôles sur qui sont diligentes
par l'agence qui ne qui ne sont pas qui
ne sont pas reçus par les ménages qui
refusent de recevoir la personne qui
vient faire des contrôles sur place le
paiement est bloqué je ne dis pas que
les cas que vous avez à me faire
remonter correspond à ça mais voilà la
typologie des difficultés que nous
rencontrons c'est de l'argent public qui
est distribué dans un certain nombre de
conditions qu'ils doivent être respectés
et l'agent comptable de l'agence ne paye
pas des dossiers qui sont irréguliers
donc effectivement parfois il faut
passer du temps sur un certain dossier
mais je reçois en tout cas l'ensemble de
vos demandes pour faire en sorte qu'elle
soit réglées s'ils peuvent si elles
peuvent être réglées deuxième point le
lien entre les la plateforme nationale
la plateforme téléphonique et numérique
nationale et le local ces liens existent
il y a un transfert d'appel qui a été
mis en place dès l'été 2020
les espaces conseils France rénovent
l'utilisent pour certains ne l'utilisent
pas pour d'autres c'est aussi des
positions individuelles ou collectives
mais le transfert d'appel c'est-à-dire
j'ai un usagé ma prime rénov qui est
bloqué avec son dossier le transfert
d'appel direct vers les services au
niveau national existent il est très
bien utilisé par certains espaces
conseils France rénov il ne l'est pas
par d'autres mais pour autant il existe
il a été mis en place et certains
espaces conseils français
avec les services de l'agence au niveau
national pour régler un certain nombre
de dossiers mais l'instruction se fait
bien au niveau national c'est une
plateforme qui a été mise en place qui
traite je le rappelle 25 000 demandes
par semaine et qui aujourd'hui ne relève
pas du local parce que si ça relevait du
local vous voyez à peu près le type de
création d'emplois que ça nécessiterait
et l’ingénierie que cela nécessiterait
mais ce transfert d'appel existe
troisième élément effectivement il n'y a
pas d'accompagnement obligatoire autour
de ma prime rénov nationale aujourd'hui
d'où la mise en place de cet
accompagnateur obligatoire à partir d'un
certain montant de travaux à compter du
premier janvier prochain qui va
permettre d'accompagner les ménages dans
ce parcours parce que le parcours reste
un parcours de travaux et d'accès à des
aides publiques qui sont complexes la
plateforme m’apprime rénove n'est pas
une plateforme de type
marchande ce n'est pas une plateforme on
commande un chauffeur ou on commande un
plat c'est une demande d'argent public
sur la base de d'un dossier qui doit
être constitué et qui doit être conforme
à la réglementation
l'éloignement pour des ménages qui sont
loin du numérique j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure que effectivement
l'accompagnement est une un des éléments
de réponse mais aussi le lien avec les
maisons françaises qui est extrêmement
important et qui a déjà été mis en place
dans certains territoires et ensuite par
rapport aux espaces ruraux j'ai fait un
tour de France cette année l'année 2022
et dans la majorité des régions j'ai
constaté que certains territoires qui
avaient des espaces ruraux
particulièrement importants avaient mis
en place une itinérance de France rénov
c'est à dire des rencontres sur des
marchés des rencontres dans des espaces
France services des rencontres dans des
locaux divers et variés avec des prises
de rendez-vous et des ménages qui se
déplacent donc au moment où c'est
permanent sont assurés suivants un
planning tout à fait intéressant et qui
montre bien que cette politique publique
effectivement ne se met pas en œuvre
exactement de la même manière dans
l'espace urbain que dans l'espace
dans l'espace rural
sur le du coup je la question que vous
avez posée madame assiatrice sur Épernay
je peux pas y répondre comme ça moi j'ai
besoin de savoir s'il y a une opération
programmée d'amélioration de l'habitat
quel est le voilà et quels sont les
freins en fait par rapport aux questions
que vous soulevez mais inaptracto tant
que j'ai pas le dossier sous les yeux
c'est difficile de savoir qu'elles
peuvent être les éléments bloquants en
fait que vous avez que vous avez que
vous avez signalé je reviens sur mon
accompagnateur Renov les missions qui
sont prévues par le décret et qui vont
être confirmés pour la constitution du
dossier par arrêter relève de quatre
ordres le premier c'est évidemment un
accompagnement technique
relatif aux travaux un accompagnement
administratif relatif donc à
l'accompagnement dans le parcours de
demande d'aide un accompagnement
économique et financier pour permettre
aux ménage de comprendre quel est le
montant de travaux et quels sont les
aides existantes qui lui de solvabilité
d'être solvabilité et un quatrième et un
quatrième une quatrième mission pardon
social notamment pour les ménages les
plus vulnérables et qui peuvent être
dans des situations de logement très
complexes qui ne
correspondent pas toujours qu'à une
réalisation de travaux
sur le sujet des entreprises peu
scrupuleuses oui il y en a c'est pas la
majorité il en existe il y a un label
RGE effectivement auquel la proportion
de d'entreprises qui ont accédé est
aujourd'hui encore insuffisant et qui
n'est pas systématiquement la garantie
ultime
j'ai pas enfin voilà je constate avec
vous mais je pense que c'est des
questions qui doivent être posées au
ministère et pas simplement à
l'opérateur qui est l'Agence nationale
de l'habitat
et au réseau et aux têtes de réseau
nationaux national pardon
donc voilà sur le sur les gains
énergétiques plus 50% de gains
énergétiques effectivement en moyenne
sur la rénovation globale c'est en
moyenne un saut de deux étiquettes
donc voilà avec plus de 50% des
logements qui ont bénéficié qui sont
sortis de leur statut de passoire
thermique ça dépend bien entendu de
l'âge du logement et de évidemment du
type de travaux qui a été réalisé
et
ensuite deux autres questions celles sur
les propriétaires bailleurs
alors et d'une manière générale sur les
propriétaires à partir du moment où un
propriétaire sollicite une aide de
l'ANAH il s'engage il s'engage à occuper
le logement pendant un certain nombre
d'années où il se cage à louer le
logement par un certain nombre d'années
et à partir du moment où ce logement est
cédé quel que soit les raisons nous
avons un pôle qui s'appelle le pôle de
contrôle des engagements qui engage des
campagnes régulières pour pouvoir
s'assurer que ces engagements sont tenus
donc avec des contrôles sur place et par
ailleurs nous sommes aussi en lien avec
les notaires qui nous font connaître
parce qu'ils savent quand la le logement
a bénéficié de cette aide et qui nous
font volonté effectivement ces sessions
donc il y a un service spécialisé à
l'agence qui s'occupe effectivement du
contrôle de ces engagements et des
recouvrements potentiels en cas de
non-respect effectivement des
engagements des propriétaires et en ce
qui concerne donc les propriétaires les
propriétaires bailleurs
multi-propriétaires les aides de la NAS
sont limitées à trois logements donc ce
sont des propriétaires bailleurs qui
possèdent au maximum trois logements et
qui sont soumis de toute façon à ces
obligations de location sur une durée
qui évidemment est contrôlée au travers
des engagements qui sont que j'évoquais
à l'instant et enfin sur la question de
l'immobilier touristique de par la loi
et de par la réglementation l'anal
intervient que sur les résidences
principales et absolument pas sur
l'immobilier touristique et dernière
question j'allais l'oublier
pardonnez-moi l'outre-mer donc en
outre-mer effectivement les aides de
Lana il n'y avait pas jusqu'à ma prime
rénov il y avait pas d'aide aux
propriétaires occupants tout simplement
ne s'occupait que des propriétaires
bailleurs puisque les aides aux
propriétaires occupants sont délivrés
par le ministère des Outre-mer au
travers de la ligne budgétaire unique
donc il y a eu effectivement une
ouverture aux propriétaires occupants
via ma prime rénov et les dynamiques
sont extrêmement intéressantes et
réellement en courbe croissance depuis
et elles sont elles sont en ligne sur le
site de la Merci beaucoup Madame la
Directrice monsieur le Président voulait
rajouter quelques précisions uniquement
des précisions puisque la diète
régionale a apporté beaucoup de réponses
pour vous dire que
moi je ne sous-estime pas les les
dossiers sur lesquels individuels sur
lesquels il y a des difficultés
étant moi-même certains le savent maire
d'une ville de 60000 habitants je mesure
parfois y compris leur des réunions
publiques ou des demandes de mes propres
concitoyens leur remarque sur les
difficultés des dispositifs que je me
mets moi-même en place comme mère
et parfois effectivement
ils peuvent pas avoir accès à certains
services parce que la plateforme
municipale n'a pas prévu le cas de
figure ou lorsque vous dépassez le
quotient familial vous avez plus droit à
un certain nombre de choses et quand
vous avez un dispositif où il y a de
l'argent public qui est engagé il y a
des contrôles et il y a une certaine
parfois rigidité qui est mise en place
pour s'assurer
que l'argent est utilisé à bon escient
et je suis moi-même destinataire à
Chambéry de dossier
de certains de vos collègues qui
m'écrivent directement en disant
monsieur le Président voilà j'ai un cas
particulier
alors c'est quoi le particulier ben la
personne par exemple qui est engagé les
travaux et décédé
donc pour le paiement mais bon on peut
pas payer parce qu'il faut on a des
règles juridiques il faut attendre
quelle est la succession qui aura la
charge du dossier les travaux ne sont
pas à la bonne adresse alors bon c'est
un problème parce qu'en fait c'est un
bâtiment d'angle il y avait deux entrées
le dossier était monté sur une adresse
et les factures ont été adressées sur
une autre adresse
non mais je vous parle de cas vraiment
qui qui sont la réalité
il y a un dossier donc qui est donné
avec un avis favorable avec le montant
de la subvention avec les entreprises
qui sont lissées
cette obligatoire puisque nous on doit
le faire avec des entreprises RG on se
rend compte que quand le dossier arrive
pour le paiement c'est pas les
entreprises qui étaient voilà elles sont
pas Hergé et bah qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
peut pas parce que si vous n'êtes pas
labellisé voilà je vais même vous donner
deux cas de figure dont je ne veux pas
que vous pensiez que c'est la règle mais
nous avons des dossiers qui sont montés
sur la plateforme puisque maintenant on
passe par des plateformes informatiques
avec des vraies familles qui déposent
des dossiers qui disent voilà le nombre
de ce qu'on doit faire comme travaux le
calcul de la prime des devis
d'entreprises RGE labellisées qui
existent sur vos territoires quelques
mois après les factures arrivent
factures acquittées
donc il y a paiement de ces factures et
parfois on se rend compte que ni les
ménages concernés ni les entreprises qui
ont envoyé des devis
n'existent dans la réalité c'est à dire
c'est des vrais ménages
c'est des vrais entreprises mais il y a
des systèmes aussi aujourd'hui il faut
se le dire
organisationnels qui ont mis en place de
faux dossiers et donc comprenez aussi
que tous ces cas de fraude
oblige et c'est normal la direction
générale d'être encore plus vigilant
parce que nous avons aussi des comptes à
rendre à nos tutelles financiers les
ministères pour savoir si l'argent
dépensé et bien dépensé tel que vous
l'avez collectivement voulu dans les
textes de loi et les
discussions budgétaires les projets de
loi de finances qui permettent à l'ANA
d'avoir ses moyens franchement voilà il
y a des difficultés parfois techniques
en 2020 me semble-t-il il y avait de
l'ordre de 6 à 7000 dossiers individuels
qui étaient planté et sans doute y
a-t-il des dossiers que vous avez connus
sur vos territoires il y en a encore
quelques centaines aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire il y a une tasse force qui
a été mise en place au sein de l'agence
avec des gens spécialisés pour aller
individuellement voir quelle est la
nature du blocage et je vous le dis il y
a une pression qui est mise sur sur la
direction générale à la fois par le
président mais aussi par le gouvernement
pour résoudre ces cas individuels pour
faire la différenciation entre les
quatre fraudes il y en a malheureusement
beaucoup dans notre pays je vous dis
devrais dossiers de vrais familles et
quand on fait des contrôles sur place de
plus en plus on dit mais attendez j'ai
jamais déposé de dossier pour acheter un
poêle à granules qu'est-ce que c'est
j'ai attendu madame de Monsieur c'est
bien vous l'entreprise qui est au coin
de la rue qui a certifié la facture oui
oui c'est vrai mais on n'a jamais déposé
de dossier voilà donc tout cela pour
vous dire que parce qu'il y a aussi de
l'argent public il y a des contrôles qui
doivent être stricts mais en résoudra en
épurat la liste qui peut à peu je vous
assure partie de 6 à 7000 dossiers en
2020 aujourd'hui ce nuit est à quelques
centaines alors je vais revenir aussi
sur un sujet sur les 80% de logements de
2050 qui existent aujourd'hui puisque
des questions
est-ce que
est-ce que le rythme de construction
aujourd'hui permettra de répondre à la
demande de nos concitoyens à être logés
alors ça c'est une question qui
appartient plutôt au ministre du
Logement et pas à l'établissement public
de la NAC et là pour accompagner les
logements déjà construits ceci étant la
question de la seconde vie est une
question fondamentale parce que on est
un pays en démographie positive que sur
nos territoires vous allez comme le
maire de Chambéry d'ailleurs de voir
appliquer un texte qui s'appelle le zéro
artificialisation net et donc que nous
avons un engagement international sur la
stratégie nationale bas carbone 0 en
2050 ça veut dire qu'effectivement
le gisement pour ne loger nos
concitoyens massivement et dans les
logements déjà existants qu'ils devront
être reconfiguré globalement en termes
thermiques mais aussi en termes de
profil pour répondre à la demande de nos
concitoyens des grands logements petits
logements enfin bref chacun sur son
territoire voit de ce dont il s'agit et
plus on remettra sur le sur le marché
des logements y compris vacants puisqu'à
10% de logements vacants en France plus
on arrivera à résoudre cette équation de
loger plus le gmu et plus d'ailleurs en
intégrera les logements vacants plus ça
laissera de la souplesse sur les
territoires ruraux pour le zanne c'est
contre intuitif mais tant que vous plus
vous investissez sur l'existant plus
vous laissez de la disponibilité sur des
terrains qui sont aujourd'hui libres
pour le secteur périphérique dans
l'importance que nous plaidons nous sur
les fonds friches par exemple pour qu'il
puisse y avoir notre
alors le fond friche inséré dans le fond
vert j'ai cru que c'était à peu près
comme ça pour que l'on puisse ne plus
impermé imperméabiliser voilà
de sujets puisque il y avait cette
question sur
les logements nouveaux et les logements
à retaper je suis désolé il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses et sur les
CRC
CRC 16h il faut vraiment prendre les ces
rapports avec un certain
recul parce que très vite au bout de
quelques semaines parfois ils ne sont
plus d'actualité tellement les choses
vont vite sur la réorganisation même du
service et le traitement d'un certain
nombre de dossiers en disant cela je
sais pas si on m'écoutera la CRC je
ressens d'autres convoqué mais c'est la
réalité et quand on publie un rapport en
disant il y a 500 dossiers qui sont
plantés ça c'est plutôt la Défenseur des
droits que dans la réalité il y en a 250
en quelques jours les choses évoluent
énormément voilà
si vous permettez Daniel salmon a oublié
un petit élément exactement merci madame
le Président de me redonner la parole
vous parliez d'argent public tout de
suite est-ce que vous pourriez nous dire
un mot sur les 30 millions dépensés par
Lana auprès de cabinet de conseils merci
effectivement enfin il y a pas de pas de
sujet là dessus il y a eu une commission
et nous avons répondu et transmis les
éléments Lana effectivement fait appel
des cabinets de conseils à un cabinet de
conseils en particulier avec lequel nous
sommes en marché tout à fait régulier
validé en conseil d'administration pour
développer ma prime rénove pour
développer France rénov et c'est
développement évidemment un coup ce sont
des développements informatiques je
précise enfin il faut que les choses
soient claires le sujet n'est pas de
nous dire quel type de politique
publique nous sommes en train de
développer la politique publique autour
de la rénovation énergétique il s'agisse
des aides ou qu'il s'agisse de
l'accompagnement et qu'il s'agisse donc
d'une générique sont des sujets qui sont
traités par les sphères ministérielles
concernées qui sont décidés évidemment
en interministériel à Matignon et qui
ensuite sont mises en oeuvre par
l'opérateur que nous sommes et nous
faisons appel effectivement à des
un cabinet de conseil en l'occurrence
nous avons acheté aussi des produits
informatiques pour développer cette
plateforme et ça fait partie
effectivement de de la régularité des
marchés qui sont posés par l'agence pour
pouvoir répondre aux missions qui lui
ont été confiées par le gouvernement
vous m'avez enfin j'avais une question
sur les délais puisque
ça a été évoqué à l'heure où nous nous
parlons je vous dis que les choses
évoluent vite c'est-à-dire que
l'info d'aujourd'hui n'est pas celle
d'il y a deux ans le délai d'instruction
d'un dossier qui est déposé qui est
complet qui est donc apporté il y a
toutes les devis en quelque sorte des
entreprises le dossier de traitement
pour avoir un feu vert aujourd'hui c'est
neuf jours sur Lana pour engager les
travaux
le délai de paiement une fois que les
factures ont été acquittées le
remboursement aujourd'hui c'est 15 jours
une fois que le dossier est déposé je
voudrais aussi dire que pour les plus
modestes il existe des dispositifs
d'avance sur subventions c'est à dire
que l'argent l'aurait
apporté en attendant que Lana leur
remboursera les subventions auxquelles
les endroits à travers plusieurs
dispositifs notamment le dispositif des
assycats prosivis sur vos territoires
qui apportent des subventions pour les
ménages les plus modestes font l'avance
et seront remboursés par ces mêmes
ménages dès lors qu'il toucheront les
les subventions de de Lana il existe
aussi des prêts qui ont été mises en
place à la suite d'une mission qui a
conduit monsieur sechel de la banque des
territoires le prêt avance mutation
distribue aujourd'hui par deux réseaux
la Banque Postale et le Crédit Mutuel si
ma mémoire est bonne parce que je m'y
perds parfois qui sont des crédits
spécifiques pour des gens qui s'engagent
dans des rénovations qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de le faire sur
lequel le capital sera remboursé
ultérieurement notamment quand il y a
une mutation du logement qui a fait
l'objet des rénovations c'est notamment
utile à la fois pour les plus modestes
mais parfois pour les plus âgés sur
lesquels les banques
je vais dire chose compte tenues de
l'espérance de vie des requérants
étaient très réticents à apporter des
avances ce prêt nouveau qui a été créé
il y a une année qui est pas encore très
connue mais c'est aussi le l'opportunité
pour moi de vous dire qu'il existe c'est
de renvoyer parfois des ménages qui ont
des difficultés avec des banques
classiques de les renvoyer vers ces deux
réseaux puisque ce prêt est aujourd'hui
en place
[Musique]